as a fat person I get a lot of abuse for
example from people in cars people is
just a nice word for men it's not to be
all like hashtag old men are trash it's
just that it's never women shouting from
cars it's just never I like your fringe
oh where did you get those glasses they
really suit your face it's like they
have this idea that fat people are so
desperate to get laid that anytime a van
blasting loud music through open windows
passes we're just like maybe that's the
one here's a public service announcement
on behalf of all fat people we don't
want you either
most of us actually have some at home at
the moment it seems as if body
positivity is the new thing it's all
over Instagram thin too may be chubby
white feminine sis women showing that
actually if they try real hard they can
look a bit fat too don't get me wrong
Society has made it very clear that no
one fat orphan should be happy with
their bodies we're all struggling but
the people who were the most oppressed
in society like actually fat people
black people and people of color queer
people trans people Muslims people with
disabilities and not at all represented
in the body positivity movement so here
is what has happened and strap in
because this is excellent information in
1967 as a lot of social movements called
for justice a fat sim was staged at
Central Park in New York five hundred
fat people gathered to eat ice cream and
burn diet books which fYI I will now be
doing every Sunday in Hyde Park
join me NASA the national association to
advance fat acceptance was founded in
America in 1969 by Bill Fabray in
response to discrimination against his
wife
hashtag we
nation ship goes the next time someone
is rude to you if your partner doesn't
start a social movement
hashtag leave him hashtag boy bye in
1973 two people called Judy free-spirit
and Aldebaran wrote the fat liberation
manifesto which called for fat people to
have equal rights declared that the diet
industry was the enemy and stated that
they were fully entitled to human
respect and recognition there were a lot
of points in the manifesto and none of
them were love your curves or hashtag
your body is beautiful because it
doesn't matter how much I love my curves
I will still be discriminated against on
a daily basis and have a harder time
buying clothes anywhere that doesn't
have flowers on it and I will still have
men shout at me from cars that has been
made into body to make it more palatable
and liberation has been made into
positivity to remove all accountability
from the perpetrators by the positivity
it's just another way of asking women to
smile thankfully women love being asked
to smile oh no wait no wait
women love having autonomy over their
own bodies I always get those two
confused
you